[Musik]
bild breaking news
jetzt also doch diktator wladimir putin
will uns den gashahn abdrehen er spricht
von einem gas ultimatum für deutschland
in einer aufgezeichneten rede für seine
russische volk macht der kreml despot
klar ab freitag also ab morgen schon
soll russisches gas nur noch in rubel
bezahlt werden würde das den krieg jetzt
auf eine andere ebene bringen darüber
spreche ich mit bildpolitik chefreporter
peter tiede peter was sagst du dazu also
sagte mir putin versucht ganz klar von
der rhetorik und von der
ankündigungspolitik her hier an der
spirale zu drehen er verschärft seine
ankündigung man muss jetzt tatsächlich
ins detail gucken wer ist davon wirklich
betroffen trifft uns das und dann muss
man tatsächlich jetzt die rede mal im
detail hören und dann auch noch mal nach
reichen was wladimir putin anderen
staatschefs in europa zum beispiel
gesagt hat aber das ist ganz klar auch
nach innen gerichtet ganz klare
propaganda ganz klare ansage ich und
westen wir sind über kreuz und nicht
viel am hut ich erkläre jetzt im westen
hier den gaskrieg und jetzt kommt es
aufs kleingedruckte anja peter die rede
war aufgezeichnet was eine
kurzschlussreaktion er ausschließt das
ganze scheint also von langer hand
geplante propaganda aktion für das
russische volk eben gewesen zu sein ja
diese verbissene rede von wladimir putin
werden wir ihnen jetzt einmal zeigen
wir müssen diese fragen insgesamt
diskutieren und wir werden darüber in
detail sprechen ich würde ganz gerne
folgendes noch mal besonders hervorheben
wir haben letzte woche darüber
gesprochen ich habe heute ein dekret
unterzeichnen wir haben dort regeln
festgelegt wie wir mit den sogenannten
unfreundlichen staaten weiterhin
hinsichtlich gaz kooperieren
unsere vertragspartner bekommen ein
klares und transparentes system um das
russische erdgas zu bekommen müssen sie
rubel konten eröffnen in den russischen
banken von diesen konten kann man dann
auch das gas bezahlen
dieses das gas das ab morgen ab dem
ersten april 20 22 4 liefert wird
wenn diese zahlungen so nicht erfolgen
würde das bedeuten dass die
verpflichtung seitens der käufer nicht
eingehalten werden mit allen
konsequenzen dann dementsprechend
kein mensch verkauft an uns etwas
umsonst und wir werden auch keine
wohltätigkeit hier fahren die
gegenwärtigen verträge werden dann
gestoppt ich möchte noch einmal
unterstreichen wenn westliche länder die
finanzsysteme als ihre waffen benutzen
wenn
firmen aus diesen ländern die ihre
verträge mit russischen banken am
physischen person nicht einhalten wenn
er unsere konten in euro und dollar
eingefroren werden können wir diese
währung diese länder dann nicht mehr
verwenden was ist denn jetzt passiert
wir haben an europäische verbraucher
unsere rohstoffe geliefert was zum
beispiel in diesem fall sie haben das
gas bekommen sie haben den euro bezahlt
und dann haben sie diese einkünfte
eingefroren in diesem zusammenhang haben
wir jedes recht zu behaupten dass unsere
gas lieferung nach europa umsonst waren
dann das kann so nicht weitergehen
und wenn wir weiter liefern sollen und
wenn die weitere gaslieferung erfolgen
wie sollen
kann es auch sein dass weitere einkünfte
bzw weitere zahlungen unsere
europäischen partner an uns bei uns
eingefroren werden und
manche westliche politiker sprechen
davon schon sie sprechen davon im
ausland und auch öffentlich so ähnlich
sagen auch und sprechen auch manche
regierungschefs aus den eu-ländern wir
haben hier große risiken und wir können
diese risiken nicht annehmen und
die zahlung in der russischen euro
wollen ist es sehr ein sehr wichtiger
schritt
die weltmärkte
stürzen ab aber die rüstungsindustrie in
den usa sie steigert ihre einkünfte
und dadurch auf grund der amerikanischen
handlung werden auch
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten in anderen
ländern gestoppt und das würde bedeuten
dass die eu aus dass teure amerikanische
gas kaufen müsste europa muss nicht nur
das portemonnaie öffnen aber auch die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit europäischer firmen
unterwandern für europa bedeutet das
eine groß angelegte die
industrialisierung und auch
arbeitsplatzverlust
gleichzeitig steigenden
lebensmittelpreise wohnnebenkosten
und darüber hinaus verringert sich auch
der lebensstandard in europa denn das
ist der preis
den die
europäer bezahlen müssen das ist das was
die westlichen eliten ihnen aufzwingen
und das ist der preis für den
wirtschaftskrieg den sie versuchen zu
führen beziehungsweise sind sie
versuchen zu entfesseln
oder vielleicht haben sie diesen krieg
schon entfesselt der bezug auf russland
und diese krieg begann nicht seid nicht
begann nicht gestern diese illegitimen
sanktionen wurden schon seit jahren
eingeführt das ziel diese sanktionen ist
russland ein zudem russlands entwicklung
einzudämmen im bereich der finanzen im
bereich der technologien und weiteren
bereichen diese sanktionen waren schon
längst vorbereitet und wären eingeführt
wurden in jedem fall diese sanktionen
sind eingeführt worden dass es der preis
den wir zahlen für unsere freiheit für
das recht und russland zu sein weil wir
nicht nach der fremden pfeife tanzen
wollen weil wir nicht nach frampton
werten leben wollen und
das sogenannte kollektive der sogenannte
kollektive westen möchte nicht von
seiner politik abkehren darüber hinaus
wird die diese westen neue vorwände
finden um sanktionen einzuführen ich
betone hier vorwände und wir können hier
keine erleichterung erweitern wenigsten
zeit deswegen bitte ich sie der russisch
die russischen banken und auch die
subjekten die russischen föderation zu
decken müssen sich darauf einstellen
dass der sanktionsdruck
beibehalten wird so wie das auch in den
früheren jahren gewesen ist das ist die
objektive realität was möchte ich hier
betonen und warum bis ich sie
fährt der kollegen wir müssen die
situation individuell betrachten in
jedem bereich wir müssen nicht nur die
gegenwärtigen herausforderungen
überwinden wir müssen auch langfristige
entwicklungspläne entwickeln und uns auf
die russische wissenschaft und auf die
russische die russische bildung und das
russische niveau stützen wir müssen auch
das geschäftsklima erhöhen wir müssen
die maximale auslastung unserer
industriezweige
gewährleisten und die russische
wettbewerbsfähigkeit auch stärken die
wichtigsten faktoren für unsere
wirtschaft müssen sein dass wir die
arbeitsplätze die anzahl der
arbeitsplätze gehören die die armut
verringern und auch dienste
die die breitere verfügbarkeit von
lebensmitteln und weiteren gütern
erhöhen außerdem der bausektor das ist
auch sehr wichtig wir werden auch in
verschiedenen industriebereichen
verschiedener sitzungen einhalten und
auch unsere luftfahrt das ist auch uns
sehr besonders ein sehr besonderer
bereich und ein sehr wichtiger bereich
für die russische wirtschaft wir haben
hier hoch technologische entwicklung und
das ist auch sehr wichtig auch für
unsere verkehrspolitik um verschiedene
regionen russlands voneinander weit
entfernt liegen zu stärken die
russischen fluglinien waren die ersten
die die auswirkung der nicht adäquaten
sanktionen seitens des westens gespürt
haben es gab verschiedene verträge im
luftverkehr bereich im zielbereich der
del der zivilluftfahrt und
wir haben hier leasingverträge die ihr
eingefroren wurden und gestoppt wurden
das heißt die russischen vertragspartner
wurden belogen und auch der luftraum für
russische fluglinien wurde auch
geschlossen und auch man muss auch sagen
dass diese internationalen firmen einen
großen reputationsverlust erlebten haben
in diesem bereich die russischen firmen
haben immer ihre verpflichtungen erfüllt
immer laufend der verträge erfüllt und
sie wollten auch dieser verträge weiter
einhalten aber die westlichen firmen und
bzw die westlichen länder haben ihre
schritte getan und wir werden natürlich
die gegen schritte einleiten die
früheren partner können wir sagen mit
den früheren partnern werden verstimmte
veränderungen eingeführt werden in der
zusammenarbeit wir werden kein
geschlossenes land sein aber wir müssen
von den aktuellen entwicklungen ausgehen
wir haben alle
wir haben allen grund
zum optimismus dass diese dass unsere
firmen diese krise überwinden werden und
wir müssen die arbeitsplätze hier
sichern wir müssen auch die
zugänglichkeit
der flüge für russische bürger auch
gewährleisten und das ist sehr sehr
wichtig dass ein kurzfristiger maßnahmen
die wir ergreifen müssen aber
langfristig gesehen müssen wir die
entwicklungsstrategie für die luftfahrt
entwickeln und uns auf unsere ressourcen
stützen
wir haben hier große möglichkeiten für
unsere
einheimische russische industrie für
russische ingenieure für russische
zubehör lieferungen
der anteil der russischen flugzeuge in
der russischen flugzeugflotte muss
erhöht werden
und das ist natürlich eine wunderbare
chance für die einheimische produktion
selbstverständlich muss die qualität
beibehalten werden und die
wirtschaftlichkeit
das ist sehr besonders wichtig für die
russischen luftfahrtindustrie
die luftfahrtindustrie muss sich
dynamisch entwickeln und auch
vorteilhaft und natürlich müssen
russische bürger in der lage sein flug
tickets zu kaufen also die preise müssen
entsprechend sein und selbstverständlich
der service der komfort muss auch nach
den hohen standards entwickelt werden
ich rede jetzt hier auch nicht nur über
die überregionale flüge ich rede auch
über die flüge mit den weit entfernten
mit den weit entlegenen gebieten ich
möchte das hervorheben
also die einheimischen fluid flugzeuge
müssen produziert werden darüber haben
wir schon öfters gesprochen aber auch
die wartung
muss auch den hohen standards
entsprechen also fangen wir an und
witali saweljew ihnen das wort bitte
schön
ja das war die aufgezeichnete rede von
wladimir putin in der er von einem
wirtschaftskrieg spricht aber peter
titel ist bei mir spricht er spricht von
einem wirtschaftskrieg aber so gut er
hier nicht eher mit einem gas-krieg für
deutschland ist das nicht eher ein
gaskrieg also putin schießt mit
platzpatronen sage ich mal ganz kurz
also
die alle europäischen staaten alle
europäischen vertragspartnern die
staaten kaufen ja nicht gar sondern
vertragspartner in den europäischen
staaten alle europäischen
vertragspartner das hat gerade der
regierungssprecher noch einmal bestätigt
hier in berlin zahlen können weiterhin
in dollar oder euro zahlen das was in
den verträgen steht in ruhe bezahlen
wäre vertragsbruch von seiten der russen
und zwar läuft das so über die
gazprombank in luxemburg die ist in
absprache mit den usa nicht sanktioniert
worden damit die europäischen firmen die
vertragspartner von gazprom zum beispiel
da weiter bezahlen können und die zahlen
auch weiterhin dort und zwar mit eur und
1 rubel und ansonsten war das eine blut
schweiß und tränen rede und eigentlich
war das eine rede in der wladimir putin
und sagt leute eure sanktionen
funktionieren hervorragend weil wir
können nicht mehr fliegen wir können
nicht mehr bauen wir kriegen eigentlich
nichts mehr richtig hin und er beklagt
unangemessen und ungerechtfertigt
aktionen und macht das was immer macht
er trennt seinen blutigen krieg seinen
überfall auf die ukraine sein
vernichtungskrieg hingegen das
nachbarland führt von den sanktionen der
tut also so als würden wir völlig
grundlos und aus heiterem himmel seinen
arbeiten mütter hier in russland
angreifen mit einem fürchterlichen
wirtschaftskrieg keiner sagen wladimir
putin hatten krieg mit heißen waffen
angriff angefangen hat ein anderes land
überfallen und der westen schlägt so
zurück wie am besten zurückschlagen kann
als wirtschaftsmacht also da demir putin
möchte man nach dieser rede eigentlich
das was wir hier immer hinter uns haben
gegeben einfach ein paar
papiertaschentücher kann dass es die
tränen trocknen unsere sanktionen wie
wir aus dieser rede sehen sorten es war
wirklich ein absolut weinerliche rede
kann man schon fast sagen unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz verkündet er
ja eben kurz vor putin eine rede und
widersprach ihm dabei will man da mal
rein
die antwort ist sehr sehr kurz wir haben
die verträge angeschaut über die
gaslieferung und die anderen lieferung
darin steht drin dass in euro gezahlt
wird manchmal dollar in der regel in
euro und ich habe in dem gespräch mit
dem russischen präsidenten klar gemacht
dass das auch so bleiben wird und wie
seine vorstellungen sind dass das
geschehen kann
das ist das was wir jetzt genau
anschauen werden aber auf alle fälle
gilt für die unternehmen dass sie in
euro zahlen wollen können und werden
doch das wollen wir einmal einen ordnen
peter was ist da los was ist in russland
los bluff putin da eigentlich als auf
ganzer ebene also wladimir putin hat
gerade aufgezählt was alles nicht mehr
funktioniert und er hat den meisten raum
hat er der luftfahrtindustrie und
dem luftfahrt wiesen eingeräumt denn das
ist in russland ich war ja nun wirklich
vier wochen da das ist zusammengebrochen
russland hat den größten diebstahl der
geschichte gemacht die haben einfach 400
flugzeuge von airbus und von boeing von
westlichen leasinggesellschaften gibt
laut die leasing gesellschaften haben
die verträge gekündigt als sanktion als
reaktion darauf auf diesen überfall auf
die ukraine und die flugzeuge gehören
den hiesigen gesellschaft nicht aeroflot
problem und er oder orale oder wie die
ganzen airlines dort heißen und das
heißt die werden nicht mehr gewartet das
heißt sie können nicht mehr fliegen zum
beispiel problem eine inlands
fluggesellschaft eine tochter staatliche
tochter von aeroflot
hat von 44 flugzeugen die boeing oder
von airbus sind noch 25 jetzt im
flugbetrieb die anderen dienen quasi als
ersatzteilspender damit man überhaupt
die anderen noch fliegen lassen kann das
ist wie zum finstersten zeiten wo man
immer fünf lkws brauchte damit zwei
fahren weil der rest waren halt quasi
ersatzteil der spender das macht mir
momentan wladimir putin hat ausführlich
darüber gesprochen dass die leute in den
entfernten regionen an preiswerte
tickets kommen müssen in russland bricht
damit ein transportwesen zusammen und
vor allem die leute fahren ja nicht mit
der u-bahn oder mit der s bahn oder mit
dem zug die drei sind nicht alle mit der
transsibirischen eisenbahn nach moskau
wenn die mal aus sibirien her müssen
nein die fliegen das flugzeug ist das
hauptverkehrsmittel
wir stehen dahinter die die haben die
propaganda und die meisten graf wieder
eine leserumfrage das ist noch ein
halbwegs seriöses umfrageinstitut in
russland gebrandmarkt auch als
ausländischer agent und die nach den
zahlen glauben von gestern 81 prozent
zustimmung zu bleiben mir putin und 71
oder über 70% zu dem krieg also das ist
aber mittlerweile aber warum ich so
mitkriegen was wirklich in der ukraine
passiert was wirklich ja was er das
müssen wir nicht nein nein dass das
wissen sie nicht und sie empfinden den
auch nicht als diktator sondern dafür
ist ganz in russischer tradition alter
sowjet tradition alte zahlen tradition
in moskau muss ein starker mann sitzt
moskau sankt petersburg da mussten
starker mann sitzen der es schlau der
ist der weiß dass alles und es weiser
mann und den braucht man auch und dieser
weise mann ist aber schlau genug sich
dann für die sachen die er selber nicht
weiß einen berater zu nehmen der im
weise ratschläge gibt und der große
weise man ist dann also genug auf diese
ratschläge zu hören diese rolle spielt
wladimir putin haben heute zum beispiel
auch die nachricht gehabt dass angeblich
putin gar nicht weiß was in dem krieg
tatsächlich passiert natürlich weiß er
dass aber er kann es ja nicht zu geben
so und das ist es und jetzt hat er
gerade auf gezählt wie wir also hat
gerade unsere erfolge im natürlich in
dem wirtschafts krieg den wir als
antwort auf seinen heißen auf seinem
vernichtungskrieg gegen die ukraine
führt da der unsere erfolge gerade auf
gezielt können wir mal ganz kurz
beglückwünschen wirkt dennoch wenn sich
die situation für die bürgerinnen und
bürger in russland jetzt immer weiter
verschlechtert wenn ihnen immer weniger
möglichkeiten gegeben werden ja ein ganz
normales leben zu führen glaubst du dass
dann auch noch kippen könnte also das
sind das ist einfach aus
die jungen leuten aber bei der masse der
leute ist das drin ist ist in der dna
drin das haben sie schon immer so
gemacht das haben sie den 90er jahren
durchgemacht das haben sie in den 80er
jahren durchgemacht das haben sie nach
dem krieg durchgemacht während des
krieges und das gehört mit dazu so lange
wie man draußen gegen die faschismus
kämpft oder gegen einen äußeren feind
ist man im inneren bereit zu danken und
ja auch wirklich schlimmes unrecht
hinzunehmen man hat keine demokratischen
traditionen woher auch und man es ist es
gibt ja diesen frei diese freiheit
erfahrungen gar nicht in die in diesem
land es gibt eine wirklich tief
verwurzelte auswahl daten und aussagen
zeiten stammende sehnsucht nach einem
großen starken mann der in von moskau
aus oder von sankt petersburg ausführt
und wladimir putin erfüllt dieses
klischee auch mit solchen reden wir
hören raus unsere sanktionen wirken die
russen höheren raus der westen bekämpft
uns wieder mal völlig ungerechtfertigt
wir sind wieder die armen alten ja auch
gerade dann in seiner rede da eben
gesagt in europa sollen die
lebensmittelpreise jetzt höher werden
die wohnsituation werden schwieriger
arbeitsplätze werden wegfallen das ist
ja so wenn man das jetzt erst mal von
hier aus hört kriegt man ja fast angst
aber das kann man nicht ernst nehmen
richtig naja also machen wir uns nichts
vor der wirtschaftskrise oder die die
sanktionen die wir machen gegen das was
wladimir putin in der ukraine macht die
kosten etwas freiheit kostet etwas
freiheit ist nicht kostenlos zu haben
das erfahren auch wir deutschen jetzt
und wir zahlen natürlich auch enorm hohe
preise für die politischen fehler die in
den letzten zehn zwölf jahren hier in
deutschland und in europa gemacht worden
sind im umgang mit russland wir waren zu
blauäugig wir sind von 30% abhängigkeit
bei gas und öl innerhalb von wenigen
jahren unter kanzler schröder und unter
kanzlerin merkel hoch auf über 50
prozent kommen ich kann man zwei
personen und das ist das ist toxisch und
den preis bezahlen wir gerade hin werden
wir auch bezahlen aber der preis den die
russen zahlen der ist weitaus höher bei
denen bricht der maschinenbau zusammen
bei denen bricht das transportwesen
zusammen bei denen werden nahrungsmittel
knapp die können sich einfach schlicht
und ergreifend keine west jeans mehr
kaufen also so meine generation kennt
noch bin im osten aufgewachsen musste
tauschen musste dem markt bringt jetzt
in russland auch nichts mehr es ist
nicht genug valuta mehr im umlauf also
in deutschland ja auch immer sorgen und
gedanken machen ist dass wir ja eben mit
diesem russischen gases die kriegskasse
eigentlich nicht bezahlen wollen aber
als er dann in dennoch tun wenn wir
jetzt in rubel bezahlen müssten würden
wir dann eben die russische kriegskasse
finanzieren so wussten wir bezahlen als
jeder also jeder kubikmeter gas den wir
aus russland kaufen finanziert die
kriegskasse über steuern direkt indirekt
darüber davon lebt der russische staat
vom verkauf von gas und öl und gucken
wir mal einfach mal auf unseren auch
ölmarkt hier bei uns reden wir nicht nur
vom vom gas wir haben vier große
raffinerien von denen hier der sprit
kommt davon gehören zwei mehrheitlich
oder mit russland also pensioniert und
anderen zum beispiel bayernoil oder aber
die große raffinerie in schwedt in
brandenburg also ich sags immer wieder
wer in berlin und in brandenburg tank zu
über 90 prozent direkt aus der kasse
oder in die gremien
und die firmen sind übrigens ja und die
firmen sind übrigens nicht sanktioniert